[Musik]
nichts nutzt ein auto so schnell ab wie
das neue auto des nachbarn lautet eine
alte weisheit aus der automobilindustrie
ein zitat aus einer zeit in der ein
sozialer stand mit materiellem wohlstand
gleichgesetzt wurde die vertriebs logik
der automobilbranche war klar definiert
aufstieg bedeutete vor allem mehr gehalt
und somit auch meist den luxus eines
eigenen autos welches im besten falle
auch durch seine größe und seinen preis
beeindruckte verbrauch oder
nachhaltigkeit in der produktion
spielten eher eine untergeordnete wenn
nicht sogar überhaupt keine rolle
erst in zeiten des stillstands zeigt
sich die wahre bedeutung der mobilität
ihre alternativen ihre perspektiven und
bewertungen das hat die korona krise
mehr als deutlich gemacht mehr denn je
steht der mobilität nun ein wandel in
unserer gesellschaft bevor dabei steht
das neue mobilitäts paradigma das dem
auto zunehmend seine bedeutung als
status objekt nimmt an erster stelle
[Musik]
lebensqualität und individuelles
wohlergehen drängen in den vordergrund
die sinkenden ökonomischen möglichkeiten
des einzelnen das steigende
umweltbewusstsein und die grundsätzliche
frage nach den wirklich wichtigen werten
im leben torpedieren bisherige vertriebs
logik dieser wertewandel schlägt in der
gesellschaft inzwischen auch auf die
fahrzeugindustrie durch in den usa
besitzen inzwischen etwa 30 prozent der
19-jährigen keinen führerschein mehr
entfielen 2007 noch mehr als 17 prozent
der neuwagenkäufer auf die zielgruppe
der 18 bis 34 jährigen so waren es laut
marktforschung letztes jahr nur noch elf
prozent
das ende des autors auszurufen wäre
nicht nur verfrüht sondern vor allem
verfehlt wir werden ganz sicher auch
weiterhin auf individualverkehr setzen
denn die werte mobilität und freiheit
besitzen dauerhaft einen wichtigen
stellenwert für menschen doch der zugang
verschiebt sich der zugang zu mobilität
wird günstiger ressourcenschonender und
letztlich auch bequemer
christie's drückt sich nicht mehr in
hubraum aus und immer seltener im
eigentlichen besitzer gerade in der
generation wird sichtbar es geht nicht
unbedingt darum ein auto zu besitzen
sondern vielmehr um den zugang dazu
nicht umsonst blühen neue
nutzungsmodelle auf carsharing zeigt
einen möglichen weg in die zukunft
mehr als 40.000 fahrzeuge stehen in
münchen berlin köln wien london
amsterdam aber auch in vielen städten
der usa und kanada zur verfügung der
markt für kurzfrist mietmodelle ist
gerade dabei sich zu definieren
viele carsharing firmen setzen bisher
auf einen mix aus postfossilen dieseln
und verbrennungsmotoren doch immer mehr
länder städte und regionen verkünden das
ende von diesel und benzinmotoren und
leuten so die ära der e mobility 1 aber
i mobility heißt dabei nicht nur
emissionsfrei
sie wird damit auch zum vorherrschenden
antrieb in der mobilitäts welt die
batterie wird die basis vor allem für
pkw und leichte transporter darstellen
wasserstoff basierte antriebe werden für
schwere transporter und lkw eingesetzt
norwegen plant es für 2025 kalifornien
und großbritannien für 2035 das ende
verbrennungsmotor ischer antriebe auch
china der größte automobilmarkt der welt
will ab 2035 nur noch umweltfreundliche
fahrzeuge zu lassen
vor allem die usa sehen sich als
autonation nummer eins mit dem wandel am
automobil konfrontiert worden wirft
einen blick in die zukunft des
amerikanischen automobils
der wettlauf um die zukunft des
automobils hat begonnen vor mehr als
einem jahrhundert leisteten die usa
pionierarbeit bei der massenproduktion
von autos wir sind weit über das model t
hinausgewachsen und das model s von
tesla hat im rennen um die elektroautos
die führung übernommen amerikaner innen
sind eher zögerlich beim umstieg auf e
fahrzeuge wie man anhand der werbung
sehen kann aber diese werbung wirft
einige ernsthafte fragen zum wandel in
den usa auf lassen sie uns mit dem
klimaexperten axa trat die einige dieser
fragen klären die frage wo stehen die
usa eigentlich wenn es um e fahrzeuge
geht offensichtlich liegen wir weit
hinter norwegen zurück
norwegen ist meilenweit voraus in
norwegen besitzen etwa 90 von 1000
leuten elektro oder plug in hybrid autos
in den usa sind das etwa 5 von 1000
und es gibt andere länder im mittleren
bereich wie etwa schweden und die
niederlande die etwas über der usa legen
es gibt also noch viel luft nach oben
norwegen ist auch ein land in dem
fossile brennstoffe wie öl und gas
gefördert werden vielleicht gibt es e
fahrzeuge auf den straßen aber es gibt
immer noch eine menge tanker auf den
meeren und vor der küste bedeutet der
schnelle umstieg auf e fahrzeuge denn
auch weniger verbrauch fossiler
brennstoffe
definitiv werden wir ein rückgang des
ölverbrauchs in norwegen sehen denn 50
bis 70 der autoverkäufer sind jetzt
bereits elektroautos aber wir dürfen
auch nicht vergessen dass die derzeitige
fahrzeug mehrheit größtenteils benzin
betrieben ist und es etwa noch 15 jahre
brauchen wird diese zu ersetzen sollte
der verkauf aller benzin autos heute
eingestellt werden
der rückgang des ölverbrauchs ist also
überschaubar und legte norwegen im
moment zwischen 10 und 15 prozent
wenn man sich die steigenden käufer von
elektroautos ansieht bekommt man den
eindruck dass die leute wahrscheinlich
er optimistischer sind was das aufladen
dieser fahrzeuge angeht denn das ist ein
großes problem auf dem markt für
elektroautos zu welchem preis kauft man
ein e auto wenn man nicht rechtzeitig
von a nach b kommen weil man
zwischendurch anhalten muss und lange
ladezeiten hat inwieweit ist das
aufladen noch ein problem
wir haben bereits seit etwa zehn jahren
elektroautos und es werden immer mehr
anfangs gab es die sorge um reichweite
wie weit komme ich mit einer vollen
batterieladung
die batterien waren teuer und die
meisten autos hatten keine große
reichweite heute besitzen diese
batterien die nötige kapazität und
reichweite
allein das aufladen stellt noch ein
problem dar
dabei dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass
benzin tankstellen seit 100 jahren auf
der ganzen welt gebaut werden das netz
zum aufladen von elektroautos ist sehr
jung wenn länder also ihre
ambitionierten verkaufsziele für
elektroautos erreichen wollen müssen sie
den ausbau eines ladennetzes
unterstützen
in den usa hat tesla hervorragende
arbeit beim aufbau seines ladennetzes
geleistet aber auch andere
autohersteller müssen aufholen oder mit
adaptern versuchen einen teil des stroms
aus dem tesla ladenetz zu übernehmen
general motors ist nur ein unternehmen
das sich an der evolution beteiligen
will während tesla einen großen
vorsprung zur konkurrenz hat beginnen
die alten auto hersteller wie ford und
vw aufzuholen viele beginnen nun die
elektrifizierung ihrer flotte
voranzutreiben bloomberg hier einmal
genauer hingeschaut
das streben nach einer wiederholung des
tesla erfolgs hält den hype am leben
teslas börsenwert ist oft über 700
milliarden dollar gestiegen mehr als
sieben der nächst größten autohersteller
zusammen das unternehmen ist jetzt eine
kategorie für sich und trotzt selbst
elon musk warnungen dass ein aktienkurs
zu hoch sei was zum großen teil dem
phänomen tesla zu verdanken ist es ist
ein allgemeiner konsens entstanden das
den elektrofahrzeugen die zukunft gehört
doch sowohl für startups als auch für
traditionelle autofirmen birgt dieser
wandel gefahren es bleiben zwei große
fragen erstens kann ein anderes startup
den erfolg von tesla sinnvoll
wiederholen und zweitens wird der markt
für elektrofahrzeuge schnell genug
wachsen um sowohl die etablierten als
auch die newcomer zu unterstützen
nikolaus dramatische aufstieg und fall
in nur wenigen monaten war das große
abschreckende beispiel des letzten
jahres das unternehmen hatte sich
vorgenommen die lkw branche zu verändern
indem es die dieselmotoren großer
lastkraftwagen durch batterien und
brennstoffzellen ersetzt die aktie
führte ihr debüt und stieg in den
sommermonaten in die höhe doch im
september brach sie ein short seller
behaupteten nicola habe die anleger
innen über seine technologie getäuscht
während die aufsichtsbehörden
untersuchungen einleiten und das
unternehmen jegliche anschuldigungen
bestritt wechselte der firmengründer zu
einem konventionellen
automobilhersteller
unternehmen wie ibm und daimler bekamen
anerkennung dafür dass sie ihr geschäft
in großem umfang umgestaltet haben auch
wenn sie dies erst spät umsetzten
während die welt noch auf den
verbrennungsmotor setzte hatte daimler
die vision bis zum ende des jahrzehnts
mehr als die hälfte seiner weltweiten
verkäufe zu elektrifizieren
aber musk hat große ambitionen
deutschland und den rest von europa zu
dominieren in den usa haben gm und ford
elektrische pickups in arbeit in diesem
segment haben sie jahrzehntelang
dominiert müssten sich aber noch in
diesem jahr mit dem tesla cyber truck
auseinander setzen
maskat sich an die spitze gesetzt kein
anderer autos lobte ihn so sehr wie
volkswagen ceo herbert diess als er den
vw ausgaben plant für das nächste halbe
jahrzehnt bekannt gab der name tesla
fiel sehr häufig dies sie tesla als
einen der wichtigsten konkurrenten und
eine referenz für vw er sagt mast habe
den nötigen software background und
fähigkeiten die andere erst noch
erarbeiten müssen einige analysten sagen
voraus dass vw und tesla in absehbarer
zukunft ein globales ivi duopol bilden
werden aber die wohl viel wichtigere
frage ist hat herbert diess verstanden
wohin sich die branche entwickelt
neo ist der jüngste hersteller von
elektrofahrzeugen wer sich dem am
schnellsten wachsenden unternehmen in
china den beinamen tesla killer
eingefangen hat der name ist berechtigt
denn china ist der größte markt der welt
doch noch vor zwei jahren war fast
bankrott hier erfahren sie wie ceo
william lee das ruder herumreißen konnte
und nun versucht es mit lenas kauf zu
nehmen in der welt der elektroautos gibt
es einen großen namen
und dann kommen alle anderen einer der
größten kunden von tesla ist jetzt china
das land wird gerade zum am schnellsten
wachsenden markt von elektrofahrzeugen
oder i wies der welt
china ist ein riesiger sich schnell
ändern damals bis 2021 sollen etwa 30
oder 40 prozent der verkäufe von tesla
aus china kommen aber es ist ein fehler
zu denken dass tesla das einzige
unternehmen ist dass ich hier auf dem
vormarsch befindet
infolge der sprunghaft gestiegenen
nachfrage gibt es in china inzwischen
über 600 wie unternehmen die mit tesla
konkurrieren wollen
neo ist eines der intelligentesten ivi
unternehmen chinas im laufe des jahres
2020 ist der aktienkurs von new um etwa
1000 prozent gestiegen anleger innen
sprechen bereits vom chinesischen tesla
oder auch vom tesla killer
neo hat viele namen aber im wesentlichen
ist es eines der vielversprechendsten
und bekanntesten unternehmen für
elektrofahrzeuge aus china
noch vor zwei jahren war das unternehmen
fast bankrott dies ist die geschichte
wie neo den drohenden bankrott abwenden
konnte und zu einem der angesagtesten
unternehmen der welt wurde das
unternehmen wird höher bewertet als der
amerikanische automobilriese gm
2020 verzeichnete das unternehmen eine
rekordnachfrage seine modellpalette
hatte ein jährliches wachstum von 121
prozent und mit der markteinführung der
et 7 limousine anfang 2000 21 machte die
aktie sofort einen weiteren sprung
ähnlich wie tesla hat sich das
unternehmen in einigen bereichen als
digitaler premium
elektrofahrzeughersteller präsentiert
aber sie versuchen auch das produkt für
chinas mittelschicht attraktiver zu
machen
sind uns von anfang an über unsere
zielgruppe im klaren der preis unsere
city serie basiert auf den
meistverkauften mittel und oberklasse
limousinen in china wie zum beispiel der
5er reihe von bmw audi a6 oder der
mercedes benz e klasse
[Musik]
aber nie gegen nicht immer den weg des
erfolgs es gibt einen grund warum die
aktien so volatil sind und zwar weil
diese unternehmen über nacht vor dem
bankrott stehen können leo war da keine
ausnahme
dieses mal ist es handelte sich um ein
kleines relativ neues auto unternehmen
das anfang des jahres mit großen
rückrufaktion aufgrund von bränden zu
kämpfen hatte die verkäufe gingen
daraufhin zurück außerdem trat sein
größter konkurrent tesla 2009/10 in den
chinesischen markt ein
neben der konkurrenz durch tesla
stagnierte der absatz von elektroautos
im jahr 2019 auch aufgrund von
entscheidungen der chinesischen
regierung die chinesische regierung hat
die direkten subventionen für
elektroautos im jahr 2009 10 um mehr als
50 prozent gekürzt das ist bis jetzt die
größte subventionskürzung chinas
doch anfang 2020 wendete sich das blatt
während china subventionskürzungen fast
das ende für new bedeuteten retteten
investitionen einer chinesischen provinz
das unternehmen so gelang es eine
vereinbarung mit der chinesischen stadt
hefei treffen im februar 2020 continuo
so sein cash flow aufrechterhalten was
ihn half ihre probleme in den griff zu
bekommen teil der vereinbarung war news
hauptsitz in der stadt hefei
einzurichten einem gebiet für
wirtschaftliche und technologische
entwicklung auch wurde den investorinnen
ein anteil von 24,1 prozent gewährt
diese waren zuversichtlich dass neo
nachdem die liquiditätsprobleme in den
hintergrund getreten waren endlich nach
vorne schauen und die produktion
steigern würde
für tesla waren produktionssteigerungen
ein großes problem denn musk versuchte
mit tesla nicht nur das auto neu zu
erfinden sondern auch den gesamten auto
herstellungsprozess und
von der herstellung erhofft sich neo
seinen wettbewerbsvorteil der news suvs
6 kostet ein drittel mehr als die
limousine model 3 von tesla neo nutzt
deshalb innovative dienstleister um
seine kosten zu senken der größte
unterschied zwischen bio und tesla
besteht darin dass neos eine fertigung
an ein subunternehmen ausgelagert hat
das über mehr erfahrung in dem bereich
verfügt
ein weiterer großer unterschied ist das
abonnement modell von ios soll den
kundinnen die angst vor dem batterie
besitz und deren risiken nehmen
kundinnen brauchen hierzu nur das auto
ohne batterie zu kaufen die batterien
können sie dann ganz einfach gegen eine
monatliche gebühr von neo mieten und
lief der letzte unterschied zwischen
tesla und neo besteht darin wie beide
das problem der reichweite angehen die
größte sorge für die kunden ist das ihre
batterie leer sein könnte bevor sie ihr
ziel erreichen
bio stellt seinen käufer innen einen
batteriewechsel service zur verfügung
neuwagen können hier an eine art rausch
station fahren und in wenigen minuten
die leere batterie ist eine vollständig
geladene batterie ersetzen lassen
direkt weiter fahren
sie gibt an bereits an einer zweiten
generation von ladestationen zu arbeiten
300 weitere stationen dieser art sollen
in china eröffnet werden der chinesische
markt für elektrofahrzeuge soll 2021 auf
1,8 millionen fahrzeuge anwachsen doch
die konkurrenz wächst hier wird nicht
nur mit tesla und anderen chinesischen
hersteller innen konkurrieren müssen
hersteller innen der ganzen welt setzen
auf den chinesischen markt für
elektrofahrzeuge und erkennen das
wachstumspotenzial
ob leo sich nicht nur den heimischen
markt sichern kann sondern auch
international ein global player wird
bleibt abzuwarten
die hersteller innen bewegen sich alle
in die gleiche richtung weg vom
verbrennungsmotor aber es gibt eine
technologie die es schon seit den 90er
jahren gibt sich aber bisher nicht
durchsetzen konnte wasserstoff
2020 war definitiv das jahr des batterie
autos aber was ist mit seinem grünen
porto der wasserstoff brennstoffzelle
präsident george hw bush rühmte 1 die
wasserstofftechnologie elon musk
hingegen verspottete sie als unglaublich
dumm die autofabriken sind gespalten
tesla und vw sind die wie champions
honda hyundai und toyota setzen auf
wasserstoff sehen wir uns an wie beides
im vergleich abschneidet die reichweite
war schon immer der hauptkritikpunkt in
dieser hinsicht scheinen wasserstoff
zellen die oberhand zu haben während das
75.000 dollar teure tesla model s long
range mit einer einzigen ladung
375 meilenweit kommt bewegen sich
billigere autos im bereich von 100 bis
200 meilen die durchschnittliche
reichweite eines wasserstoff zellen
autos beträgt etwa 250 meilen und laut
der britischen fachzeitschrift autocar
übertrifft der nexxo suv von hyundai den
tesla mit einer realen reichweite von
414 meilen
während das aufladen eines
elektrofahrzeugs stunden dauern kann
lassen sich wasserstoff zellen im besten
fall in derselben zeit auftanken wie ein
benzin fahrzeug das brennstoffzellen
derzeit noch zu schaffen macht sind die
kosten und die effizienz laut der
horváth & partners haben
batteriebetriebene elektroautos einen
wirkungsgrad von 70 bis 80 prozent das
heißt von der stromerzeugung durch
turbinen oder kraftwerke bis zum
fahrzeug es gibt wenig energie verloren
der wirkungsgrad von wasserstoff
fahrzeugen liegt dagegen nur bei 25 bis
35 prozent der elektrolytische prozess
zur herstellung von wasserstoff gefolgt
von der komprimierung und dem transport
des gases kostet und geld so dass ein
wasserstoff fahrzeug für die gleiche
strecke wie ein elektrofahrzeug etwa
dreimal so viel energie benötigt
die effizienz und die hohen
wartungskosten von wasserstoffautos
haben den kampf zugunsten von
batteriebetriebenen elektrofahrzeugen
für den pkw weitgehend entschieden
batterien haben jedoch einen nachteil
bei kapazitätserhöhung sinkt die
reichweite
brennstoffzellen hingegen können ihre
reichweite wie benziner erhöhen man bot
einfach einen größeren tank
dies eignet sich für nutzfahrzeuge sogar
für schiffe und den luftverkehr und
genau in diesem bereich investieren
honda und toyota die frage ist also
nicht entweder batterien oder
wasserstoff zellen auf dem weg zu einer
umweltfreundlichen mobilität werden
beide benötigt
so viel zu den vor und nachteilen bei
der antriebsarten aber lassen sie uns
die unternehmen näher betrachten die
sich auf wasserstoff konzentriert haben
hierzu ist uns rüber davis aus tokio
zugeschaltet fangen wir mit der
wissenschaft dahinter ahnen wie wird
wasserstoff eigentlich hergestellt
wasserstoff ist wirklich erstaunlich da
ist das am häufigsten vorkommende
element auf unserer erde ist das aber
nur in verbindung wie zum beispiel mit
wasser vorkommt muss der reihe
wasserstoff der in brennstoffzellen
verwendet werden kann erst hergestellt
werden
[Musik]
es gibt mehrere gängige verfahren zur
herstellung von wasserstoff ein wirklich
interessantes verfahren ist die
elektrolyse dabei wird wasser mit hilfe
von elektrizität in wasserstoff und
sauerstoff aufgespalten
sehr interessant an diesem verfahren ist
das bei der erzeugung von strom aus
erneuerbaren energien wie wind oder
sonne während des gesamten prozesses der
wasserstoff herstellung keine
kohlenstoff emissionen entstehen
wir hören ja viel über e wie unternehmen
viele investieren in batterieantrieb
aber welche etablierten autokonzerne
investieren speziell im wasserstoff
drei große namen die hier genannt werden
müssen wenn man über brennstoffzellen im
personenverkehr spricht sind toyota
hyundai und honda diese unternehmen
haben jetzt bereits kommerzielle
brennstoffzellenfahrzeuge auf dem markt
und setzen sich vom rest der branche ab
die sich zunehmend auf batterien
konzentriert wie zum beispiel general
motors ford oder mercedes benz alle
diese automobilhersteller wendeten sich
von wasserstoff ab und konzentrieren
sich nun auf batterien
in der vergangenheit lag die hoffnung
bei personenkraftwagen auf wasserstoff
aber in zukunft werden diese beiden
technologien einen anderen platz
einnehmen
der markt und akteure wie toyota sind
sich einig dass batterien bei
personenkraftwagen eine größere rolle
spielen
wenn es um langstrecken transporte oder
schwere und große fahrzeuge geht wird er
wasserstoff eine führende rolle spielen
das liegt an seiner hohen energiedichte
die für busse oder lastkraftwagen eher
geeignet ist um längere strecken zu
bewältigen
im vergleich zu benzin hat wasserstoff
etwa die dreifache energiemenge pro
gewichtseinheit mit dem toyota mir kann
man so bis zu 850 kilometer weit fahren
es handelt sich also um einen sehr
energiedichten kraftstoff der in zukunft
in größeren fahrzeugen eine rolle
spielen wird um sogar darüber hinaus
viele analysten sind der meinung dass
wasserstoff und 20 jahren sogar an der
schifffahrt oder in flugzeugen eine
entscheidende rolle spielen wird
riesa davis unsere reporterin in tokio
vielen dank für ihre zeit
die verstopfte arterien unsere mobilität
trägt zum raschen klimawandel bei nach
angaben der vereinten nationen entfallen
fast 25 prozent der emissionen auf autos
busse und lkws hinzu kommt der faktor öl
in den usa gibt es bereits anzeichen
eines zenits unsichere geopolitische
risiken könnten die volatilität des
ölpreises befeuern dies bringt uns dazu
über unsere abhängigkeit vom öl
nachzudenken sind elektrofahrzeuge die
antwort auf dieses problem
ich denke es ist finanziell unsinnig
irgendetwas anderes als ein elektroauto
zu kaufen das durch autonomie
aufgerüstet werden kann
egal was sie von elon musk alten er hat
seit zehn jahren die richtige idee und
während andere autohersteller versuchen
aufzuholen sind elektrofahrzeuge längst
einer der innovativsten märkte überhaupt
schon im neunzehnten jahrhundert waren
bereits viele autos mit elektroantrieb
unterwegs und wurden in zeitungsanzeigen
wie hier in pittsburgh beworben doch
1908 führte henry ford das gasbetriebene
motto t 1 bis 1927 perfektionierte fort
das fließband und baut rund 15 millionen
model ticks erst dann mitte der 60er
jahre sehen wir wieder elektroautos
meist sind das konzept modelle wie der
henne kilowatt in den späten 90ern auch
bekommt die welt einen ersten eindruck
von hybriden darunter der toyota prius
der im jahr 2000 in die amerikanischen
autohäuser rollt drei jahre später wird
tesla gegründet und 2008 stellt das
unternehmen den tesla roadster vor es
folgen das model s extreme und weitere
modelle gleichzeitig erweist sich asien
als starker konkurrent der nissan leaf
wird 2010 zur meistverkauften
elektroauto der welt und china zum
größten markt für elektroautos zu den
investoren gehören jack ma und warren
buffett
das alles bringt uns zum heutigen tag
bloomberg new energy finance geht davon
aus dass china in vier jahren mehr als
drei millionen elektro fahrzeuge
verkaufen wird in den usa werden bis zum
jahr 2021 schätzungsweise eine million
modelle auf den straßen unterwegs sein
aber wie genau funktioniert ein
elektroauto und was ist drin hier gibt
es antworten
elektrofahrzeuge autos die mit batterien
betrieben werden sie funktionieren auf
viele verschiedene arten sehen wir uns
tesla an ein akku mit einer reichweite
von 300 meilen besteht aus 7000 lithium
ionen zellen im inneren der batterie
winzige lithium ionen bewegen sich von
der kathode zur anode die batterien
bestehen aus nickel kobalt lithium und
aluminium
diese batterien haben es in sich sie
haben eine hohe lade und entladezyklen
also eine menge energie und man kann sie
oft wieder verwenden um eine überhitzung
der batterie zu vermeiden wird bei der
wechselstrom technik eine kühle
flüssigkeit verwendet die zwischen den
batterien fließt der wechselrichter
nimmt diese energie auf und wandelt sie
in wechselstrom um eine art spannung die
sich ständig ändert von dort aus erzeugt
er ein rotierendes magnetfeld im motor
und energie entsteht der antriebsstrang
verteilt diese energie auf die räder
strom der nicht verbraucht wird zb beim
bremsen wird in die batterie
zurückgespeist der 36.000 dollar teure
chevy volt kommt mit einer akkuladung
238 meilenweit ein tesla model s chf 315
meilen danach kann man das auto in etwa
30 minuten an einer station aufladen zu
hause kann es bis zu einem tag dauern
der clou ist dass die batterie niedrig
und flach auf der unterseite das auto
sitzt ähnlich wie bei einem skateboard
der niedrige schwerpunkt sorgt für ein
besseres fahrgefühl aber rechnet sich
das auch die durchschnittlichen kosten
für benzin in den usa liegen bei 2
dollar 55 pro gallone bei elektroautos
liegen sie bei 1 dollar 21 also 50
weniger allerdings umso weiter man fährt
desto teurer ist das auto preise für
imis liegen zwischen 30.000 180.000
dollar aber der hype ist groß die
persönlichkeiten sind groß einer der es
genau wissen sollte ist einer der
mittlerweile reichsten menschen der welt
elon musk aber wer ist dieser elon musk
eigentlich
der milliardär und unternehmer hamas
klasse seinen worten taten folgen ich
stehe persönlich und mit meinem ganzen
vermögen für meine produkte ein
sein größtes kapital ist seine fähigkeit
seine visionen und träume zu
verwirklichen und andere menschen davon
zu überzeugen
entschlossen konnte er mit seinen
visionen gleich drei branchen verändern
ich wünsche allen beteiligten viel glück
und drückt uns die daumen da kommt ein
typ aus südafrika nach amerika und sagt
weißt du nasa diese ganze raketen sachen
ich glaube ich habe etwas besseres und
dafür riskierte er alles
wir hatten gerade mal geld für etwa eine
woche damals musste ich eine
entscheidung treffen entweder nahm ich
das gesamte kapital das sich durch den
verkauf von paypal an ebay übrig hatte
und investierte es in tesla oder tesla
wäre am ende
andere waren nicht bereit dieses risiko
mit ihm oder seinen firmen einzugehen
doch seine rechnung ging auf wir haben
nicht nur das kapital zurück gezeigt wir
haben es mit zinsen und einer
bonuszahlung zurückgezahlt letztendlich
hat der us steuerzahler also einen
gewinn von mehr als 20 millionen dollar
aus diesen darlehen gezogen doch elon
musk hat visionen die ihm vielleicht
dorthin bringen wo vor ihm niemand war
er geht immer einen schritt weiter sein
ziel der mars auf lange sicht würde ich
wirklich gerne zum mars fliegen das ist
das übergreifende ziel von spacex
als ich ein kleines kind war hatte ich
wirklich angst vor der dunkelheit aber
dann habe ich verstanden dass dunkelheit
eigentlich nur die abwesenheit von
photonen im sichtbaren
wellenlängenbereich zwischen 400 bis 700
nanometern bedeutet es ist schwer zu
glauben dass der unternehmer es jemals
angst vor etwas hatte
dann dachte ich das ist doch albern
angst vor einem mangel an photonen zu
haben und danach hatte ich keine angst
mehr vor der dunkelheit
ein kind sagte zu ihm du dir den mond an
er ist millionen kilometer entfernt
sagte nein eigentlich weniger als 250
tausend meilen und sie sagten elon
musk hat sein leben damit verbracht den
leuten zu beweisen dass sie falsch
liegen nachwuchs in südafrika auf war
das älteste von drei kindern und wurde
ein jahr früher eingeschult sein vater
war ingenieur seine mutter male war
model und ernährungsberaterin
brillanter junge deshalb war er bei
einigen
ich war ein bücherwurm und
wahrscheinlich auch ein kleiner
besserwisser was natürlich für ein kind
schwierig werden kann also habe ich
einfach viele bücher gelesen und
versucht den leuten in der schule aus
dem weg zu gehen
sein sozialleben war viel weniger
ausgeprägt als dass meine anderen beiden
kinder eben ein typischer ich habe alle
comics gelesen und nicht im laden oder
in der buchhandlung finden konnte ich
lass alles was ich in die finger bekam
von morgens bis abends irgendwann ging
mir die bücher aus ich begann in secure
medien zu lesen
und der hat ein fotografisches
gedächtnis so dass er sich alles merken
kann immer wenn ich eine frage hatte
sagte meine tochter tosca fragil on sein
bruder kindle maske als er zehn jahre
alt war wurde er testete und man stellte
fest dass er eine der größten begabungen
für das programmieren von computern
hatte ich versuchte einige computer
kurse zu besuchen aber ich war dem
lehrer weit voraus also fing ich an
einen weltraum spiel namens blaster zu
programmieren musk fing an wie ein
unternehmer zu denken und fand heraus
wie er sein spiel verkaufen könnte aber
ich war 12 und wusste nicht wie
wir beschlossen in der nähe unserer high
school eine spielhalle zu eröffnen wir
waren große fans von videospielen wir
dachten es wird ein riesiger erfolg wir
mieteten also ein gebäude versorgten die
spielhalle und kümmerten uns um die
lieferung der geräte am ende mussten wir
nur noch die genehmigung der stadt
einholen aber die genehmigung der stadt
muss von einem erwachsenen beantragt
werden und ihre eltern hatten sie nicht
eingeweiht
natürlich sagte man uns dass wir keine
spielhalle eröffnen würden max chef kin
ist ein technologie und
wirtschaftsjournalist der elon musk
bereits mehrfach porträtiert hat das
erstaunlichste an seiner kindheit ist
wohl seine flucht aus südafrika
ich weiß noch wie großartig ich damals
amerika fand hier gibt es mehr
möglichkeiten als in jedem anderen land
der welt amerika ist das land der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten
durch seine auswanderung konnte musk
auch seiner dienstpflicht in der
südafrikanischen armee entgegen
im südafrika der apartheid aufzuwachsen
war ziemlich surreal ich meine wir haben
diese regierung nicht unterstützt und
nicht an sie geglaubt somit stand die
idee zum militärdienst zu gehen wirklich
nicht zur debatte ich erzählte meinen
eltern dass ich nach kanada gehen würde
sie versuchten mich natürlich davon zu
überzeugen nicht zu gehen und schon flog
er los ich dachte wow so unabhängig doch
als er gelandet war rief er mich an und
fragte und jetzt
was soll ich sagen von montreal nach
vancouver konnte ich kanada vom highway
aussehen
er hielt sich mit gelegenheitsjobs über
wasser bevor er ans queens college in
toronto
an der uni war ich nur selten beim
unterricht ich habe nur das lehrbuch
gelesen und mich auf prüfungen
vorbereitet der große reiz an der uni
war dass sich dort mädchen in meinem
alter treffen konnte so wie meine erste
frau
nach einem abschluss in ingenieurs- und
wirtschaftswissenschaften erhielt er ein
stipendium für stanford doch silicon
valley the place to be
ich wollte einfach dorthin gehen wo die
wirklich spannenden dingen stattfanden
elan hatte die fähigkeit sich die welt
anzuschauen und zu sagen das kann in 20
jahren ein echtes problem werden er sah
sich um und stellte fest dass die welt
verändernden dinge nicht ins der in fort
stattfanden
ich bin nicht einmal zur vorlesung
gegangen ich rief den vorsitzenden des
fachbereichs an und sagte ich möchte es
mit meinem eigenen internet unternehmen
versuchen und wenn es scheitert möchte
ich sicherstellen dass ich trotzdem
zurückkommen kann meine kinder machen
komische sache aber ich habe mir nie
große sorgen um sie gemacht wenn irland
des college verlassen wollte konnte er
jederzeit wieder zurück mein bruder war
zu der zeit in kanada und ich meinte ich
denke wir sollten versuchen ein internet
unternehmen zu gründen also kam er und
schloss sich mir an er hatte gerade mal
2000 dollar keine freunde kaum genug
geld für eine wohnung ich glaube er
erzählte mir dass er im fitnessstudio du
still weil es dort wo er wohnte keine
dusche gab wir haben einfach ein paar
fotos besorgt die tagsüber als couch
dienten mehr und sich nachts in betten
verwandeln ließen steve johnson ist
risiko investor im silicon valley ich
traf ihn und seinen bruder campbell zum
ersten mal mitte der 90er jahre ich
glaube sie waren etwa eine woche hier
und stellten gerade ihr neues
unternehmen namens sieht vor in den
späten 90er gab es einen regelrechten
goldrausch die leute strömten nach
silicon valley um im internet geschäft
fuß zu fassen und reich zu werden muss
hatte die idee anzeigen zu
digitalisieren er nahm eine cd der
gelben seiten eine karten software
schrieb ein wenig code und fügte alles
zusammen um die ersten online städte
anzeigen zu erstellen
allen war visionär und mastermind ich
habe mich um den verkauf gekümmert ich
hatte immer noch meine grundlegenden
programmierkenntnisse so dass ich in der
lage war die software für unser erstes
unternehmen zu schreiben als elend damit
anfing war das internet gerade mal ein
paar jahre die meisten lokalen
unternehmen waren nicht im internet
vertreten wenn man nach einem geschäft
suchte musste man die gelben seiten
aufschlagen
wir dachten uns das medienunternehmen
die zeitungen hilfe brauchen viele ihrer
anzeigenden website zu übertragen jemand
hat uns buchstäblich die gelben seiten
vor die füße geworfen und gefragt
glauben sie dass sie das jemals ersetzen
werden und wir dachten der typ sei
verrückt denn das war ja erst der anfang
und gingen noch viel viel weiter
es dauerte nicht lange bis sich media
unternehmen aus dem ganzen land männern
so konnten wir die new york times
knight ridder und eine reihe anderer
unternehmen als investoren und kunden
gewinnen
1999 kaufte dann altavista compact für
307 millionen dollar in bar und 34
millionen in aktienoptionen musk war
damals gerade 28 jahre alt
ich dachte das ist total verrückt dass
jemand so viel geld für unser kleines
unternehmen bezahlt von norwegen über
deutschland bis hin zu china wurden
milliarden an subventionen ausgegeben um
autofahrer innen zum kauf von e-autos zu
bewegen in china dem größten markt der
welt stiegen die verkäufe von elektro
autos bussen und kommerziellen e
fahrzeugen im jahr 2018 auf 1,3
millionen ein enormer anstieg huang gang
er gilt in china als vater der
elektroautos
der verkauf von fahrzeugen mit
erneuerbarer energie ist um fast 60
prozent gestiegen dies zeigt ein sehr
schnelles wachstum das zeigt uns dass
wir auch autos mit erneuerbarer energie
setzen sollten
[Musik]
heute sind es dieselben sorgen wie in
den siebzigern verlässlichkeit und
kosten wenn sie ein e auto für 30.000
dollar kaufen kann es bis zu sechs
jahren dauern bis sich diese investition
amortisiert bessere batterien und mir
ladestationen können hier helfen
in der zwischenzeit setzen
autohersteller in der falle sie
investieren milliarden von dollar um
evans zu entwickeln die nicht rentabel
sind sie sind gezwungen partnerschaften
mit konkurrenten einzugehen um die
rentabilität zu erhöhen wer auch immer
die richtige formel findet könnte der
große gewinner sein werden sie an der
spitze einer neuen revolution stehen
oder werden ihre träume wie vor 100
jahren zerschlagen
ford hat sich dazu verpflichtet bis
20.30 kohlenstoff neutral zu sein damit
sind wir in unserer branche viel hand
denn wir sind überzeugt dass die zeit
für die automobilindustrie reif ist
ford sorgte mit seinem mache eine
e-version des mustangs für aufsehen
die herausforderung für das design
bestand darin das was bei
elektrofahrzeugen fehlte mit der
leidenschaft für mars drinks zu
verbinden
2020 sollen 40 prozent der modelle
elektrifiziert sein wir gehen davon aus
dass bis mitte des nächsten jahrzehnts
50 prozent der verkauften fahrzeuge bis
zu einem gewissen grad elektrifiziert
sein werden es gibt natürlich einen
großen markt für hybridfahrzeuge und das
wird auch in zukunft unsere dominierende
technologie sein toyota ruft bis 2030
auf weltweit 5,5 millionen verkäufe
was ist das nächste große ding für vw
und
das ist es das elektroauto das für viele
unserer kunden wirklich die beste wahl
ist
volkswagen hat gerade sein budget um 36
auf 60 milliarden euro erhöht um bis
2025 80 neue modelle zu produzieren etwa
15 bis 16 prozent unserer verkäufe
werden auf e fahrzeuge entfallen es wird
eine neue welle revolution kommen und
wenn sie da ist wollen wir ganz vorn
dabei sein mit modellen unter 33.000
dollar versuchen sie den budget markt zu
erobern audi wird in nur fünf jahren 20
modelle auf den markt bringen man sieht
einen trend zur elektrifizierung einen
trend zur konnektivität was kommt also
als nächstes eine menge sehr viel
es haben sich seit dem monat stark
verändert wie geht es nun weiter
schauen wir uns tesla an sie haben in
letzter zeit erfolge erzielt das model
free ist das meistverkaufte elektroauto
in den usa und ließ die konkurrenz
hinter sich noch ist rentabilität ein
problem je mehr autos tesla verkauft
desto mehr geld verlieren sie der umsatz
pro einheit ist im dritten quartal
weiter gefallen und setzt damit andere
autohersteller unter druck
immer stärkere produkte werden auf den
markt kommen auch die marktdurchdringung
nimmt zu es gibt unterschiedliche
meinungen darüber wie schnell der markt
wächst aber er wächst und wir müssen
unsere anteile sichern
ich glaube nicht dass der größte
konkurrent von tesla toyota oder general
motors ist es werden die großen
technologieunternehmen die eine billion
dollar oder mehr wert sind mehr als alle
autofirmen zusammen das sind unternehmen
die in der lage sind talente und kapital
anzuziehen und die es sich leisten
können geld zu verlieren ist mit
jemandem wie tesla aufzunehmen
eigentlich perfekt oder die leute wollen
die autos die autofirmen liefern fertig
leider nicht denn hier ist das problem
konzerne müssen rund 141 milliarden
dollar für die elektrifizierung ihrer
flotte ausgeben man schätzt dass die
produktion eines 12.000 dollar teurer
ist als die eines benziners also ein
henne-ei-problem die konzerne brauchen
der käuferinnen diese brauchen mehr
auswahl um überzeugt zu werden das
bedeutet auch mehr verlust aufgrund der
produktionskosten
unternehmen müssen die kosten für teile
wie batterien senken analysten schätzen
dass dies noch mehr als fünf jahre
dauern könnte in der zwischenzeit sind
sie gezwungen partnerschaften einzugehen
um die rentabilität zu steigern
psa peugeot will bis 2023 80 seiner
modelle elektrisch betreiben und sich
jetzt mit vier zusammenschließen um die
kosten zu senken
dieser wandel in der branche wird für
viele oems eine herausforderung
darstellen es wird eine art
darwinistische phase geben die nächsten
jahre werden schwierig
ich denke die vorstellung und dass ein
einzelnes unternehmen alleine in diese
neue zukunft investieren wird ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich
ford und vw kooperieren um elektrische
autonome autos zu entwickeln
der geschäftsmann ihnen würde so etwas
nicht tun aber ihre
führungspersönlichkeit verlangt dass von
ihnen
ford wird batterieautos auf einer vw
plattform bauen und vw wird 2,6
milliarden dollar in die ford-tochter ag
investieren selbst für zwei so große
unternehmen ist es sinnvoll sich einen
teil der anstrengungen zu teilen damit
sie schneller und effizienter werden
vw und sein chinesischer partner
investieren bis 2020 mehr als 4,4
milliarden dollar in die produktion der
markt um sofort zu wachsen ist bereits
da und es ermöglicht diesen unternehmen
schneller mit erschwinglicher
technologie auf den markt zu kommen die
verschafft ihnen jetzt vielleicht sogar
einen kleinen wettbewerbsvorteil
gegenüber denen die erst ein paar jahre
allein versuchen
ich glaube niemand investiert gern in
eine ungewisse zukunft doch was bleibt
ihnen übrig die wies die bisher auf den
markt gekommen sind konnten tesla nicht
vom thron stoßen mercedes hat seine edi
us-debüt gerade um ein jahr verschoben
um die nachfrage zu befriedigen sind die
originalteile hersteller oems also
aufeinander angewiesen laut mckinsey
können zwei von ihnen die gemeinsam eine
spezielle plattform entwickeln die
kosten um 1500 bis 2000 dollar pro auto
senken viele dieser partnerschaften sind
bisher mit batterie firmen geschlossen
worden volkswagen bmw volvo und tesla
schließen batterie verträge im wert von
mehreren milliarden dollar ab um sich
kapazitäten zu sichern gm hat sich mit
lg chemical zusammengetan um eine fabrik
für elektroautos in ohio zu bauen sie
müssen kosten senken und synergien
finden um so mehr geld für investitionen
freizusetzen
einige autofirmen sind wirklich spät
dran und haben akzeptiert dass sie sich
in dieser hinsicht voll engagieren
müssen
aber sie werden viel unterstützung durch
behörden und regierungen benötigen das
wird leider nicht einfach sein
volvo und geely fusionieren und planen
bis 2025 jedes jahr ein neues modell auf
den markt zu bringen um seine co2 bilanz
zu verringern ergeben sie fast 50
milliarden dollar aus auf der consumer
electronics show in las vegas waren
amazon insel qualcomm und blackberry mit
daten verarbeitenden dienstleistungen
die verbesserten chips und sensoren für
autonome autos die technik kann bei der
kartierung und navigationssystemen
helfen laut intel wird dieser markt bis
20.30 einen wert von dreieinhalb
milliarden pro jahr erreichen es ist ein
computer auf rädern es ist ein gerät das
über seine funktion als mobilgerät
hinaus betrieben werden kann
letztes jahr wurden weltweit mehr als
zwei millionen elektro autos gekauft im
jahr 2025 sollen es um die 10 und 2040
sogar 56 millionen werden tendenz
steigend aber elektroautos müssen
billiger werden 35 prozent des preises
machen momentan noch die batterien aus
diese linie hier zeigt kosten eines
normalen verbrennungsmotors und
verdeutlicht dass e fahrzeuge bis 2024
noch immer teurer sein werden dann tritt
eine wende ein es werden viel billiger
und die kosten für batterien sinken es
gibt viele faktoren eine heim
ladestation verzögert die preisspanne um
ein bis drei jahre in china wird es
länger teurer bleiben weil die
autopreise dort niedriger sind als in
anderen ländern in den usa gibt es
steuergutschriften von 20 bis 70.000
dollar für die ersten 200.000 verkauften
autos je nach größe der batterie
bundesstaaten können auch
subventionieren zum beispiel in
kalifornien wo die verkäufe von
elektroautos seit 2017 sprunghaft
angestiegen sind kalifornien ist somit
der zweitgrößte käufer von elektroautos
der welt
[Musik]
ohne eine deutliche steigerung von
elektrofahrzeugen werden wir unsere luft
für den großstädten nur schwer sauber
halten wir müssen also die werbetrommel
rühren und müssen nach unserem geld auch
taten folgen lassen indem wir anreize
schaffen mary nichols vorsitzende der
kalifornischen luftreinhaltung behörde
und treibende kraft für saubere luft
es ist nicht nur der finanzielle anreiz
der größte anreiz ist die tatsache dass
man einen aufkleber für die
fahrgemeinschaft spur bekommt auch wenn
man nur einzelfahrer ist das ist das was
mehr pendler aus der mittelschicht dazu
bewegt hat sich für das elektrische
fahren zu entscheiden
senator chuck schumer hat einen 454
milliarden dollar plan bei dem kunden
einen bargeld gutschein erhalten wenn
sie ältere benzinautos gegen
elektroautos oder andere hybridfahrzeuge
eintauschen zum teil präsident der
american energy alliance hält nichts von
subventionen und es befürworter der
freien marktwirtschaft
eine der autoren senator hat' sagte wir
begrenzen die zahl der fahrzeuge auf
200.000 pro unternehmen weil wir nicht
wollen dass alle von den subventionen
abhängig werden
wir wollen die technologie vorantreiben
und dann die industrie von dort aus
weiter machen lassen
subventionen können immer auch in
falsche hände geraten die
aufsichtsbehörde tk hat festgestellt
dass 70 millionen dollar an autokäufer
gezahlt wurden trotz unzulässiger
anträge warum ist noch unklar
die ars aber hat bisher keine
möglichkeit solche fälle zu verhindern
senator bill cassidy kritisierte die
kredite man müsse sicherstellen dass sie
wies von wohlhabenden gekauft und nur
für weniger wohlhabende subventioniert
würden
[Musik]
unterm strich sollte sich die regierung
nicht damit befassen gewinner und
verlierer der branche heraus zu picken
aber selbst mit subventionen erreichte
der absatz von e wie es in den letzten
zehn jahren nur zwei prozent der
gesamten autoverkäufe und dann ist da
noch europa die verkäufe sind hier 2009
10 sprunghaft angestiegen in norwegen
sind 42 prozent der neuwagenverkäufe in
norwegens ziel ist es bis 2025 alle
neuwagenverkäufe emissionsfrei zu
gestalten die europäische kommission
nicht gerade viel druck aus um ihre co2
emissionen zu verringern die ziele der
nächsten 20 30 jahre können ohne
fahrzeuge nicht erreicht werden
verbesserungen am verbrennungsmotor
allein werden hier nicht ausreichen
europa norwegen und andere dieser länder
sind ganz anders strukturiert ihre
bürger haben eine viel höhere toleranz
gegenüber steuern und der einmischung
des staates in ihr leben es ist ein ganz
anderer markt ein viel kleineres land
sie konzentrieren sich mehr in den
städtischen gebieten
norwegen ist führend bei der
mehrwertsteuerbefreiung für lebensmittel
dafür werden höhere steuern auf benzin
fahrzeuge erhoben was verbraucher innen
dazu zwingt sich für weeze zu
entscheiden deutschland hat norwegen
beim verkauf von ews knapp überholt das
land hat außerdem 54 milliarden euro für
den kampf gegen den klimawandel bereit
gestellt teilweise sind die subventionen
für imis der bonus von bis zu 57 1000
euro wird zur hälfte von der
autoindustrie getragen damit sollen bis
zu 700.000 fahrzeuge gefördert werden
sie betrachten den ganzen automarkt in
deutschland frankreich oder uk beträgt
der anteil an den verkäufen immer noch
wenige prozent dennoch schnell steigend
china begann 2009 mit der
subventionierung von e-fahrzeugen für
ihre öffentlichen flotten 2013 dann auch
für endverbraucher innen 5000 bis 8000
500 dollar je nach reichweite des autos
werden direkt an den hersteller gezahlt
bis 2025 sollen sieben millionen hybride
und brennstoffzellen autos auf den markt
kommen
[Musik]
china hat mehr als 30 milliarden dollar
für die subventionierung ausgegeben die
verkäufe sind seitdem sprunghaft
angestiegen nun hat china die
subventionen um 50 prozent reduziert
2021 sollen sie vollständig auslaufen
die auswirkungen sehen wir bereits die
verkäufe sind darauf sechs monate in
folge zurückgegangen
die in den nächsten zwölf bis 24 monaten
drastisch gekürzten und damit
wegfallenden subventionen werden sich
auch auf die märkte auswirken
rheingau ist ehemaliger wall street
banker und jetzt präsident von expand
china
diese neuen akteure werden nicht das
zeitfenster haben dass wir hatten um mit
unterstützung der regierung in den markt
zu kommen und einer sehr geringen
staatlichen unterstützung konfrontiert
sein
[Musik]
china entschied sich nun gegen
subventionskürzungen und fällt
zusätzlich mehr geld in den ausbau von
ladestationen stecken china hat achtmal
soviel ladestationen wie die usa je
dunkler das rosa desto mehr
ladestationen und fast alle befinden
sich in kalifornien
langfristig wird die maßnahme den
gesamten sektor zu gute kommen denn die
subventionen selbst kommen den anbietern
des unteren marktsegment zu gute die
abschaffung oder kürzung der
subventionen zwingt die verbraucher sich
auf die produktdifferenzierung die
qualität und das leistungsversprechen zu
konzentrieren
in den usa ist es ähnlich sollte ein
konzern 200.000 verkäufer erreichen
fallen subventionen weg gm und tesla
haben diese marke erreicht und mussten
nun einen rückgang ihrer quartalsumsätze
hinnehmen
letzten endes erhalten die konzerne die
subventionen wenn auch nicht direkt es
ist der einzige weg elektroautos mit
profit zu verkaufen
in der anfangsphase sind subventionen
also unumgänglich
wenn man die subventionen abgeschafft
werden die autohersteller versuchen ein
besseres produkt auf den markt zu
bringen das erschwinglicher ist
man überlegt diese kredite bis 2024 zu
verlängern und erst ab 600.000
verkauften fahrzeugen zu begrenzen
unternehmen wie tesla würde dies viel
mehr spielraum geben elon musk feiert in
shanghai seine erste tester fabrik
außerhalb der usa tesla könnte so zu
einem der dominierenden wettbewerber
verwies auf der ganzen welt werden
elektroautos machen fünf prozent der
neuwagenverkäufe in china aus die
regierung möchte diesen anteil auf 25
prozent steigern die bekämpfung der
umweltverschmutzung ist eine priorität
für präsident jean ping jeder schaden
den wir der natur zufügen wird
irgendwann auf uns zurückfallen das ist
eine realität der wir uns stellen müssen
in china sterben viele menschen an
lungenkrebs oder schlaganfällen die auf
die hohe luftverschmutzung
zurückzuführen sind
china ist bei der einführung der
elektrofahrzeug technologie führend und
sieht auch seine zukunft in der branche
genug geld ist vorhanden
hunderte von chinesischen autofirmen
werden von milliardären unterstützt alle
wollen die nummer eins sein wie expand
und sein model free ein tesla konkurrent
der nur halb so viel kostet wenn sie zu
den spitzenunternehmen gehören haben sie
keine schwierigkeiten kapital zu
beschaffen jack ma von ali baba hat sein
geld in den wall street veteran in bryan
gut von expand investiert 2009 10 waren
es mehr als 900 millionen dollar weitere
400 millionen aus unternehmen wie chemie
experte 2009/10 bisher 11.000 autos
verkauft treibende kraft war hong kong
der 2011 chefwissenschaftler das projekt
wurde
der klimawandel liegt in unser aller
verantwortung wir müssen begreifen dass
wir zu den weltweit größten kohlendioxid
produzenten gehören seit mehr als fünf
jahren befassen wir uns intensiv mit
diesem thema
china plant bis 2035 60 prozent seiner
verkauften autos mit elektromotoren zu
betreiben außerdem wollen sie mindestens
20 neue standorte für auto und andere
industrie schaffen
wir sind in der verantwortung in
missionen zu reduzieren wir haben einen
beitrag zur ökologie und unserer
zivilisation zu leisten
sehr verantwortungsbewusst wirte aber
möglicherweise nicht jedem chinesischen
ivi unternehmen das überleben sichern
bas chinas größter hersteller von iwf
rechnet mit einem verlust warren buffett
speedy meldete im oktober einen
gewinnrückgang von 89 prozent und einem
gewinnrückgang von bis zu 43 prozent im
jahr 2019
dann ist da noch nie das von thoni mara
und seiner firma tencent unterstützt
wird 2017 gab es eine investition in
höhe von einer million us dollar das
unternehmen hatte allerdings in den
letzten jahren verluste von fast sechs
milliarden us dollar gemacht man kann
von einem vier oder fünf jährigen
kleinkind nicht verlangen dass es geld
verdient das ist bedenklich
kostenüberschreitungen schwache
verkäufer und eine rückrufaktion für
etwa ein viertel der fahrzeuge zwangen
die etwa 20 prozent seiner belegschaft
zu entlassen
leo hat circa 1,7 millionen yuan kosten
pro auto das für nur ein drittel der
kosten verkauft wird werbeaktionen wie
null prozent zinsen und garantierte
subventionen für autos die vor februar
zugelassen werden sollen tesla den kampf
ansagen wir beabsichtigen in china
weitere investitionen zu tätigen und auf
zu erhöhen und tesla ist nicht das
einzige ausländische unternehmen audi
plant in den nächsten zwei jahren neun
weitere modelle in china
bmw wird ab 2022 den extreme cross auf
ein china bauen und arbeitet an einer
e-version seines minis
es geht nicht allein darum den
chinesischen markt zu erobern wir wollen
auch forschung und entwicklung betreiben
das evd team wächst wir denken über
einen liefer netzwerk nach mit dem wir
gemeinsam intelligente produkte
entwickeln daimler und chili haben einen
780 millionen dollar trend venture
gegründet um zusammen an selbstfahrenden
autos zu arbeiten wir werden gemeinsam
den smart entwickeln und 2022 mit einer
neuen produktgeneration am markt sein
wir sind sehr gespannt darauf
wie schnell die welt auf e fahrzeuge
umsteigt ist eine frage des geldes es
kann noch fünf bis sechs jahre dauern
bis sich der kauf eines 30.000 dollar
teuren e autos in den usa lohnt die
batterie preise müssen sinken die
batterie preise sind seit 2010 um 89
prozent gesunken aber das wird sich
möglicherweise bald ändern das problem
sind die lithium produzenten sie haben
ihre produktion auf hochtouren laufen
lassen weil sie auf eine steigende
nachfrage durch elektrofahrzeuge gesetzt
haben doch die erwartet hohe nachfrage
blieb aus somit gab es niedrigere preise
durch überproduktion etwa 70 prozent der
weltweiten lithium vorkommen sind in der
hand weniger unternehmen in südamerika
es wird durch traditionellen bergbau
oder als sole gefördert hierzu werden
große mengen wasser ins erdreich gepumpt
und anschließend salzhaltiger schlamm
abgetragen in großen becken gelagert
verdampft die sohle vor der verarbeitung
es dauert drei bis fünf jahre bis eine
neue mine in betrieb gehen kann in den
nächsten jahren muss viel investiert
werden um die nachfrage zu decken
wir schätzen dass bis 2025 rund 80
prozent der gesamtnachfrage auf
elektroautos entfallen wird also ein
sehr großer teil
bloomberg geht davon aus dass der markt
für lithium batterien in zehn jahren ein
volumen von 116 milliarden dollar haben
könnte aber preise müssen sinken 2009 10
kostete eine batterieeinheit 156 dollar
pro kilowattstunde je billiger die
batterie desto günstiger das auto und
desto schneller die akzeptanz
ein weiteres problem von lithium kobalt
und nickel ist dass sie möglicherweise
nicht so umweltfreundlich sind wie man
denkt das 20 jahrhundert war das
zeitalter des verbrennungsmotors das 21
jahrhundert wird der batterie gehören
bis 2040 wird die mehrheit der weltweit
verkauften autos von batterien
angetrieben werden die weit weniger
schadstoffe ausstoßen als benzinfresser
doch die in batterien verwendeten
elemente haben ihre eigenen
herausforderungen
lithium benötigt viel wasser bei
niedrigen lithium preisen könnte sich
der bergbau nicht mehr lohnen und die
industrie könnte auf die ökologisch
riskantere methode setzen salzwasser in
den untergrund zu pumpen um es als sole
zu gewinnen nickel wird in kathoden von
lithium ionen batterien verwendet um die
energiedichte zu erhöhen so können iwes
schneller und weiter fahren doch sind
bergbauunternehmen überhaupt in der lage
eine stetige nicke lieferung zu
garantieren
kobalt hat ein ethisches problem es
schützt die batterie beim laden vor
überhitzung doch die bedingungen für
bergleute im kongo dem weltweit größten
produzenten sind schrecklich einige der
arbeiter sind gerade einmal vier jahre
alt ein sauberes auto bedeutet also
nicht immer dass es sauber hergestellt
wird
manchmal können lithium-ionen-batterien
in brand geraten sie können sich
überhitzen und sauerstoff frei setzen
der ein feuer verursacht einige dieser
brände lassen sich auf
herstellungsfehler oder sogar auf
überladung zurückführen eine mögliche
lösung wäre die flüssigkeit in batterien
zu wechseln
eine alternative können festkörper
batterien sein anstatt flüssigkeit
enthalten diese glas keramik oder ein
anderes festes material
diese könnten die risiken einer
entflammbarkeit verringern sowie dünnere
und kleinere akkus ermöglichen die unter
den autositz passen
ein weiteres problem sind die
ladestationen es gibt nicht genug und
die die es gibt sind nicht schnell genug
ende 2018 gab es weltweit mehr als
630.000 ladestationen 460.000 davon
allein in china nur ein viertel der
ladestationen gilt als schnell genug die
meisten liegen eher im mittleren bereich
die autokonzerne kritisieren diese
infrastruktur die momentan zu den
größten hürden des marktes zählt
müssen die initiative ergreifen um die
lade infrastruktur zu verbessern ich
würde mich über eine stärkere
zusammenarbeit in europa und den
regierungen in der ganzen welt freuen
die infrastruktur die wir haben muss
besser werden wir werden europa alle 120
km mit schnellladestationen ausstatten
wir bieten sowohl ladestationen für das
eigene haus als auch für öffentliche
stromnetz
es herrscht eine allgemeine reichweiten
phobie und der grund dafür ist wie immer
die ladeinfrastruktur die nicht schnell
vorankommt
wir arbeiten eng mit herstellern
zusammen und fragen nach wie viele und
vor allem wo es im umlauf sind um unsere
ladestation zu platzieren wo sie
gebraucht werden somit können käufer im
sicher sein dass eine infrastruktur
vorhanden ist
rigobert schneller der geräte mit 50
kilowatt und arbeitet mit messern und gm
zusammen wir arbeiten mit list und mit
menschen zusammen wir sind teil des
leasingprogramms von gm die uba und
lifte wie es zur verfügung stellt die
entwicklung nimmt rasant zu und zwar
nicht nur in kalifornien auch in städten
wie atlanta und sie hatte
ego hat inzwischen mehr als 1000
ladestationen und konzentriert sich auf
den einzelhandel
wir haben eine kooperation mit safeway
wir sind partner von kroger und hofu
sehr wichtiger partner für
anwendungsfälle ladezeiten die dauer
eines einkaufs sie schließen die autoren
die ladestation an besorgen ihre
einkäufe kommen wieder heraus und ihr
auto ist aufgeladen
ein anderer anbieter ist stadium 2001
gründeten die mitglieder eines solaren
teams eine firma die ladestationen die
in zehn minuten mehr als 215 meinen
reichweite bringen tesla verspricht eine
aufladung von 75 meilen in fünf minuten
auch lose it bot leichter batterien für
rennwagen mit einer ladung erreicht man
eine höchstgeschwindigkeit von 174
meilen pro stunde und eine um 20 prozent
höhere batterie dichte der einsatz
dieser technologie könnte die
ladeinfrastruktur grundlegend verändern
eine weitere option ist das kontaktlose
laden
seit über zehn jahren versuchen wir das
kabellose laden von elektrofahrzeugen zu
perfektionieren
alex cruisen leitet ein team von
wissenschaftlern bei city und mobile
elektronische geräte mit dem stromnetz
zu verwenden
der strom wird hier effizient über eine
distanz zum beispiel von einer spule im
boden ihrer garage übertragen stellen
sie sich ein patt von der größe eines
pizza kartons vor dass sich mit einem
empfänger am boden ihres fahrzeugs
verbindet
toyota lizensierte diese technologie bmw
nutzt sie bereits für seine 530 e
modelle
man kann nicht über elektrofahrzeuge
sprechen ohne dabei das thema autonomes
fahren zu erwähnen theoretisch könnte
ihr auto über eine software verfügen die
auf knopfdruck aktiviert werden kann die
sogenannte erwies gibt es nicht nur bei
elektroautos aber wenn autohersteller
über die zukunft sprechen liegt dieser
aspekt auf der hand
nennen wir unseren computer train stufe
eins sie und jane linken und
beschleunigen gemeinsam stufe 2 jane
lenkt und beschleunigt und bremst man
achtet selbst aber noch auf den
straßenverkehr stufe 3 jane überwacht
auch die fahrzeugumgebung sie müssen
aber bereit sein das auto zu
kontrollieren stufe 4 jane fährt
komplett autonom kein eingreifen mehr
nötig und stufe 5 bedeutet jane macht
alles sie sind nicht einmal im auto
damit können 94 prozent der durch
menschliches versagen verursachten
unfälle vermieden werden
stufe 4 könnte bei privatfahrzeugen bis
mitte der 2020er jahre eingeführt werden
tesla hat bereits rund drei milliarden
meilen autonom zurückgelegt doch das ist
sehr kostspielig investoren haben in den
letzten neun jahren bereits 14
milliarden dollar ausgegeben wobei die
meisten eine markteinführung 2022
anstreben
nicht gut sind van thom bremsung und das
nicht anhalten bei gefahr gut sind
ausweichmanöver die notbremsung und die
fahrer warnungen
toyota investierte viel in die
technologien etwa drei milliarden dollar
für sensoren entwickler und
dienstleistungen bmw daimler und vw
investierten 2015 ca 3 milliarden
us-dollar der größte elvis' deal aller
zeiten general motors ist ebenfalls
unter den top five das unternehmen hat
jetzt eine bewertung von 19 milliarden
dollar
volkswagen investiert der 2,6 milliarden
dollar in fords autonome unternehmen
ford kaufte argo 2017 für eine milliarde
dollar und wird bis 2023 noch einmal
vier mal so viel investieren
[Musik]
wir müssen uns fragen die sich
carsharing auf den gesamten verkehrs
markt auswirken wird
die welt der ews und erwies
überschneidet sich beim thema mobilität
sie können mit einem über- oder mit
einem autonom fahrenden auto zur arbeit
fahren
der us markt für carsharing soll bereits
150 milliarden dollar umfassen und
autonome taxis könnten weitere
milliarden einbringen bloomberg geht
davon aus dass mobilitätsdienste bis
2040 19 prozent der insgesamt mit dem
pkw zurückgelegten kilometer ausmachen
werden nur wo ein kalifornische startup
will leichte autos bauen die lebensmitte
oder mahlzeiten nach hause liefern
bereits nächstes jahr werde nur
lebensmittel von kuka und dominos in
houston ausliefern viele sind der
meinung dass jedes elektroauto das nicht
über eine eigene plattform verfügt bei
der entwicklung ins hintertreffen
geraten wird sie werden mit kosten
nachteilen und mangelnder begeisterung
der verbraucher innen zu kämpfen haben
nun scheint man sich uneinig zu sein
wann es soweit sein wird
der nächste schritt nachwies und elvis
sind fliegende autos über und hyundai
haben sich zusammengetan um ein
fliegendes taxi zu entwickeln das taxi
soll senkrecht starten und landen platz
für vier passagiere inklusive besatzung
besitzen es soll bis zu 200 meilen pro
stunde fliegen und mit einer reichweite
von 60 meilen voll elektrisch betrieben
werden boeing airbus daimler toyota und
porsche investieren ebenfalls in diesen
sektor der markt von lufttaxis könnte
bis ende des nächsten jahrzehnts fünf
milliarden pro jahr betragen
[Musik]
experten sind sich einig das auto der
zukunft wird in ein größeres netzwerk
aus verkehrsinfrastruktur elementen
integriert sein im preis der jahreskarte
für die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel ist
vielleicht auch carsharing integriert
oder die leasingrate und die garagen
gebühr ist im park and ride für die
busfahrkarte inbegriffen
der zugang zu mobilität wird günstiger
ressourcenschonender und letztlich auch
bequemer neue verkehrskonzepte klingen
nicht nur intelligent sondern auch
logisch aber vielleicht ist genau das
der denkfehler denn das auto ist nicht
nur praktisch sondern prestige objekt
auch wenn es sich beim kauf oft um
rationale argumente dreht ist in
wahrheit auch eine emotionale
entscheidung der grund dafür wer so viel
geld für einen gegenstand ausgibt muss
auch eine emotionale beziehung dazu
aufbauen das auto ist projektionsfläche
der persönlichkeit es wird zu einem
avatar für seinen besitzer
man muss das auto in seiner gesamten
rationalität verstehen autonomie
bestreben macht selbstdarstellung oder
auch abkapselung von der außenwelt
gelten als treibende faktoren für die
lust am autofahren
wie wird die zukunft der mobilität
aussehen welche entwicklungen werden
wirtschaft und gesellschaft beeinflussen
unsere mobilität beschreibt die
entstehung einer mobilen welt kultur
deren veränderung wird durch neue
produkte und service ist bestimmt aber
auch die zukünftige nutzung von
verkehrsmitteln
es liegt also in den händen alle
verkehrsteilnehmenden nicht nur in denen
der autofahrenden
[Musik]